if i was 19 and i was on a
college campus and they announced that
some
50 year old with a bunch of degrees was
coming to speak i would never go like
not
over my dead body i'd just be like oh
okay
all right and then someone would go
well adam he's going to talk about stuff
you disagree with and i'd go well he's
50 and has all the degrees so i guess
i'm probably wrong
and then someone would go
do does he have the right to speak here
and i go
of course it's not my campus i'm just
i'm i'm i'm basically this is a
four-year motel i'm living at i don't
own the building like who know something
for me to and then if they went we're
going to go rally and make create a
human blockade i'd be like why why just
don't go to the show
well i don't i don't get it and i
realized sort of like a sane functioning
person that's what you're saying you
would have acted like a
female should be well
how high does your self-esteem have to
be to go not on my watch
you link a lot of this stuff that's
happening on colleges in the movie you
link it to sort of how we've raised kids
now so you want to you want to kick the
millennials while they're down i do
i do as as i as i
travel through this land i think
i think the self-esteem movement has
really
is really the genesis of this we started
because i started thinking like
when i was 19 i didn't have any
self-esteem and
my thing was like i'm not going to tell
an adult what to do like i would never
dream if i was walking down the street
and i was like
16 and i'd passed a 45 year old guy and
he just went hey stop not one well i
need to go give me 20 push-ups
okay diamond hands or kind of do a wide
spread like i would have just done it
because he's a dude and he's older than
me and he told me to do something that's
how i was wired so
i started thinking like
well if i were 19 and i was on a college
campus
and i was on a construction site but if
i was on a college campus and by the way
when i was on a construction site i had
a foreman go
he said go to my truck get my forefoot
level out of my gun rack he had like a
four foot level hanging on his gun rack
and i said
okay and i started walking the truck and
he goes hey
run and i started running because he
told me to run because he's older than i
am and she had a gun rack so it was
probably a wise yeah where's the gun
run it probably wasn't all levels in
there
so
i started thinking
if i was 19 and i was on a
college campus and they announced that
some
50 year old with a bunch of degrees was
coming to speak i would never go like
not over my dead body i'd just be like
okay
all right and then someone would go
well adam he's going to talk about stuff
you disagree with and i'd go well he's
50 and has all the degrees so i guess
i'm i'm probably wrong and then someone
would go
do does he have the right to speak here
and i go
of course it's not my campus i'm just
i'm i'm i'm basically this is a
four-year motel i'm living at i don't
own the building like who knows it's not
for me to and then if they went we're
going to go rally and make create a
human blockade i'd be like why why just
don't go to the show
well i don't i don't get it and i
realize sort of like a sane functioning
person that's what you're saying you
would have acted like a 19 year old
should be well
how high does your self-esteem have to
be to go not on my watch
no way as
as david rubin or jordan
sorry jordan rubin or dave ben shapiro
sorry you're combining all these people
combining them into one
one
horrible transforming yeah that's gonna
be that's gonna be protested why
would why why would that be my job
who am i to do that so if you think
about what that takes
that takes a life of grooming that takes
a life of don't let anyone tell you what
to do
you tell them what to do like you're
special
your opinion matters don't let anybody
you know
how so the self-esteem movement i
believe is super dangerous i mean
how are you gonna put
world war ii get in a higgins landing
craft and go hit normandy
19 year olds with super high self-esteem
you think they're getting in that thing
you think they're gonna russian german
pillbox hell no
no so this thing that we thought was
good like hey what if everyone just felt
really good about themselves like
that's good if you earn it
if you just
rub it on them
that ain't earning it and that's going
to lead to trouble so if we go a little
meta on that do you think that's
actually by design do you think that is
just like it's sort of just kind of like
liberals that wanted everybody to feel
good and it's just kind of nice or do
you think it was actually by design by
some some bad actors that push this
stuff out there to to weaken all of the
things that you that the movie's about
i think
it can be traced back to a gentleman
who's out of los angeles who
had an idea which is like
it was
and all paraphrased but it's like some
of these inner city kids and some of
these low-income kids or
single parent kids and stuff
they have low self-esteem like they
don't their dad abandoned them like they
don't feel good about themselves and if
they felt good about themselves they
would start excelling in school and get
out of gangs and not be involved with
crime so
how do we get them to feel good about
themselves and it's like well we can't
get their dad back in the house and we
can't give them an a in calculus when
they're failing calculus we're just
going to start telling them how good
they are and they'll feel good about
themselves and what ended up happening
is it turns out like criminals have high
self-esteem like
they didn't know
it's a unintended circumstance like i
have a good heart you know it's it's
basically all that stuff of like i have
a good heart let's build
big housing projects and let people live
and free in those and we'll give them
food and we'll level it's like yeah
you're really good it all sounds good
you have a great heart you've now ruined
a group of people that's how you ruin
people you you tell them you give them
things without earning it you give them
food without earning it you give them
housing without earning it or you give
them self-esteem without earning it you
don't earn it it doesn't work it morphs
into something bad and then comes back
in a weird kind of
vitriolic way yeah this this is seen by
everybody yeah i would think right as
long as youtube lets it get to the feed
and youtube and now so every person that
subscribes you make money
no
you do make money if they roll ads on
this we make money but you may do they
roll ads on this it depends on what we
talk about so you may be deemed too
controversial to i'm not controversial
i'm on fuller house
that's on netflix it's a very family
oriented show yeah what do you need to
sell what product would help you make
money on this
well you know whatever they want to lay
in before this i don't care what they
put in before that's the funny thing no
one associates the ad
with the content you know so they just
want me not to say anything offensive so
that the advertiser won't say okay sag
it talked about whatever like a fabric
softener because one of those sheets one
of those sheets that's like a good thing
i would love to have fabric i like
fabric software it's great stuff
and who said to me what a bounce you
have on your jacket yeah that was
perfect perfect
outfit and we compliment each other i
feel good about this i think it's
i think it's i think we're crushing this
let's talk about this full house thing
hit it had not heard of it until i did a
little research for this right
apparently it was a big sitcom
yes it was it was for eight years and i
didn't know either yeah i just knew i
had a place to go to work and then i
paid for kids private school yeah so i
told you this when we had dinner a
couple weeks ago but my sister was she's
nine years younger than me she was so
and i know you hear this all the time
but she was so obsessed yeah with that
show that we were never allowed to watch
tv at dinner in my family that was it we
would sit and and have a good time or a
bad time or argue or laugh or whatever
but my sister at some point took control
of the family
and suddenly full house was being
watched during dinner right she loves
that she loves stamos
everyone loves dating yeah it's true
everyone loves statements no tell me a
little bit about getting in on that and
how that differed from stand up and then
suddenly even though you had studied
acting and all that but just like doing
something that was so different
completely different um i'd always
wanted to be on a sitcom i'd been around
them
you know i'd
as i said i was a warm-up on bosom
buddies i would go visit robin doing
work and mindy i would sneak into happy
days i snuck into the bob newhart show i
was under age you had to be 16 or 17. i
snuck into mary tyler moore
i would watch them filming these shows
james l brooks
producing mary tyler moore show
unbelievable and i saw bob newhart last
night had the name drop wants to know
when we can go to dinner
didn't mention you that's don rickles
that that is a direct lift
of the kind of thing he would say i mean
that's perfection yes that really is
comedy yeah he would say something like
somebody very famous
you know i saw someone last night
i saw i saw chris rock last night didn't
mention you yeah you know just to just
let you know i think rickles could make
it now just because of the way we are
about it he was making it uh in an as a
new guy as a new young comedian uh
impossible
but there's a new way to do it
which is a way of love and some people
do it and some people make fun of
everyone my friend jeff ross is the
roast master general
you know there there are
ways to bash people but it's turned mean
and what happened is and this is an
understatement
you know the roast i was roasted on
comedy central but i had john stamos was
the roast master i had all my friends
were there i got to pick who was on it
most people don't you know justin bieber
roast no one knows him you know
most of the people
and people think roasting people is
supposed to be mean
and it's a if it doesn't come out of
kindness and love of the person
or just blind i'm going to attack them
but there's no attachment of anger to
this
it's just evil it's just wrong and we
are in a society where people will
they'll hit you back on a tweet they'll
watch something you'll see people on the
news you'll listen to political leaders
talk you'll hear people bash each other
back and forth and it comes from
don rickles
thinking that that's what he did
that's not what the man did the man
would
would just you know see a man and a
woman in the audience and say is this
your wife the guy would go yes and dom
would go oh
[Laughter]
and that's just
but and his age had something to do with
it but also
his tenacity
and his and he started in the lounge at
two in the morning doing three shows
till five in the morning yeah and
talk about the trenches and all love so
if someone comes out and makes fun of
people
and does it out of love
or does it have a truth that's the
safest way we're at right now that's
where the chappelle
thing comes through that's where you
look at certain people um
i really enjoy mark maron a lot
bill burr
i mean there's so many people that are
so good
um
that that some people
don't even
know about that sell out places
constantly that are just like brian
regan and just he's so he's brilliant i
mean he cares three new hours he's like
what
and it's clean or you go see seinfeld do
what he does and you go that's why he's
jerry seinfeld yeah
because it's not just word smith he's
connected to everything he did it might
be word for word in some ways but
another night but
my god it's fun yeah and you know and
then i'll you know i love anybody who is
funny who
just is there to entertain people and
it's not only about them which is hard
because we're a very narcissistic group
right i mean comics are particular
there's a certain breed of craziness
right that comes with comedy the best
line i ever heard about that was was
i've mentioned this a few times george
carlin on the view
once and he's sitting there with all the
women around him i was talking about you
know he was giving he was he was selling
or they had just come out with like this
anthology so that's what he was there
for but he said something about how to
be a good comic you have to have a ton
of [ __ ] like you have to have all this
pain and all this angst and all this
stuff but then at some point
you got to conquer it because otherwise
it'll conquer you and that's why so many
comics die of drug overdoses and all
this other stuff
yeah but if you can own it then you
could be 62
and i'm gonna be doing i don't know if
i'm gonna be doing stand up at 90 but
i'll be doing forms of it yeah you know
you couldn't stop even if you wanted to
right i could not stop working i i i
just directed this movie benjamin which
i'll talk about at length in the third
hour of our interview
but but i i have to leave after hour too
but you're welcome i'm gonna stay yeah
we're just gonna keep going it's just
gonna be me and the camera
but but i
i love working without it i
i'm an artist
and it sounds so fruity pebbles to say
that but i just am and i always will be
and i'll be making whether it be
directing or writing or performing i
love acting there's no limit as long as
you can stand and walk and bend and
remember things you know
you know yeah not fall into an open
trunk
right the memory one goes first because
now there's guys on broadway that are
using uh
isps earwigs yeah i was gonna say uh
ibib what's the intercontinental ibm
missiles yeah not those that's that's a
difference no no that has been known and
i hopefully will uh live long enough
that at 92 years old i'll be on broadway
and i'll have an airway again and
they'll feed me the lines and i don't
care
if i'm good if it's done right i saw
peter o'toole and amanda plummer and my
fair lady the most miscast version of my
fair lady on broadway yeah and i think
he had a thing in his ear he was no
child when he did it playing
that character is very fascinating
because my fair lady which is a play i
don't know if people are familiar but
sometimes the audience goes a little
it's it's a this school tiny bit older
but it's not a millennial's favorite but
you know she it's pygmalion which of
course loses more people gen x doesn't
even follow pygmalion right now but it
what's amazing about it is he's 40 years
older than her
and no matter how you play that play
yeah that is a musical with rex harrison
and audrey hepburn he's 40 years older
than her he is
maybe 50 but he's 60 and she's 20 and
that's that
and uh he's trying to make her a classy
woman
in a chauvinistic misogynistic
unacceptable way and it is one of the
best musicals ever written for people
that don't know that was the original
premise of or that was the original
inspiration of pretty woman right right
that is true i'm not making that up
right no you're not all right now you're
not he's trying to make an honest woman
yeah out of uh an honest hooker yeah all
right let's talk about this full house
thing
so then right from honest hooker
speaking of honest hookers you did it i
was gonna let you drop one of the girls
names but okay no so all right so then
you suddenly you're on television
everyone knows who you are
uh i was fired from a morning program on
cbs which was against good morning
america and today show for being too hot
for morning tv they had another actor
play the character of danny tanner um i
always feel bad about that that's oh
really
highlight was shot with a pilot was shot
with someone else makes me sad but the
same producers and other people in this
business have done that before with many
many shows robin williams was not the
first mork
the perfect strangers was was not uh
marklin baker it was there was a gay
housekeeper in the pilot episode of the
golden girls that guy got the boot i but
that's what i played on full house
anyway
but but i ended up with the part because
i was fired and they made it available
for me and um
jeff franklin the exec producer wanted
me originally for it and bob boyet and
tom miller who
still produced fuller house um
it's a complicated thing show business
it is so complicated all you want to do
is entertain a bunch of people yeah and
then all this stuff happens and i played
a character because i wanted to be on
three men and a baby had just come out
we were talking about that before we
yeah we're rolling on this fantastic
showbiz
we saw the gutenberg at dinner that
night we did see the gutenberg and he
brings his bible he didn't have the
bible with him yeah and uh that went
over almost he had the faith
he had the fish and he had enough for
everyone
and the water guess what it turned it so
anyway um sorry so
this this part was something that i
wanted and three men and a baby with
stephen and ted danson and um
tom selleck uh yeah
uh had this come out and so we were that
we were you know dave and john dave
coulier and john demos were already
diapering ashley and mary kate and i was
not in those scenes so they re-shot the
pilot and all of a sudden the show abc
thought they could keep it on it doesn't
happen like that anymore they they put
it on twice a week it ran on tuesdays
didn't run on fridays
and then they started to run it twice a
week for a while and then they ordered
more episodes and it wasn't doing very
well but they believed in it and we were
on against seinfeld which also wasn't
doing very well right that so that's
around what like 89.90 now
87.88 oh wow yeah yeah so then 89 is yes
we're not doing well
and then after four years we started to
do well we switched studios from
sony because i know people want to give
their demographics right on google maps
to warner brothers to be on the same
stage exactly where fuller house is done
now wow that's pretty good and did the
last four years there
and then it was a really big hit and of
course
with network television if you look at
ratings now
you go oh my god how could they cancel
it with that share insane and then we
were offered to go to the cw or the wb i
can't remember what it was at first
because it's all a blur we were offered
one more year to go there and we just
kind of said
john and i i kind of
i thought we did it you know we kind of
got canceled so why do we want to beg to
go somewhere else yeah and they do that
sometimes with sitcoms and it never
works right no you're somewhere else and
then people find it what they do it for
is facilitation
so oh
what years is that from everything looks
different
set looks smaller right but it was
the secret to that show was that there
was actual affection between the cast
and uh and and good writing and good
moral things where kids could watch your
sister could watch it yeah and feel good
yeah afterwards say hi to my sister
talia talia uh you were great in rocky
yeah and that's right that's right
there you go and i just uh
your brother loves you very very much
and
and really appreciates that you would
make them all watch full house instead
of have a nice nice dinner
that did make the dinner nicer all right
let's do just a little bit more on tv
and then i want to talk politics with
you and just sort of laugh
you're a deep you're a philosophical guy
i am a philosophical guy it gets me in
trouble sometimes so you do fuller house
yes big star
then you're also doing america's
funniest home videos another thing where
it's a blooper show and i'm playing on
sunday night seven to eight o'clock at
night people were in church that day so
then that night
i'm hosting a show that has to be done
very palatable
for america and the world it was number
one in china was that hard for you
because you i mean you really had to
handle that
that was that yeah you know it was a
little difficult and it was a gift horse
so the tree opens up
you know it's the number one show the
producer vindabona called me one day on
my curly cord car phone
and said we're number one and i said you
mean peepee and he went no he said we're
we're number
one huge it was it was a phenomenon and
the the joke is if you wanted to
see a man get hit in the nuts you had to
come through me i was the gatekeeper my
guest this week for the new revamped
relaunched fan-funded reuben report is a
comedy legend an activist an author an
actress an entrepreneur and a former
presidential candidate
roseanne plus mother and grandmother
don't forget the most important part i
should have done those two first right
but you know that's how you are
that's okay you've
i've made the correction all right let's
jump right into arthur there that's so
rad there's bee you told me once i loved
her that you loved her but you also told
me that you thought that the gay
community rallied behind the golden
girls in a weird way that they didn't
quite behind you even though you were
actually doing a lot more pro-gay stuff
because you did the first gay kiss which
we'll talk about later and all that
stuff is that a weird thing because it
was sort of like the connors were
sort of the reverse of what people think
of as gay as over the top and flamboyant
and the connors were working class
that's not thought of
as yeah
some some
some working class people are gay there
are they are some of them are gay
they're not on bravo though well they're
gonna they're right next to bravo on tlc
like the duck dynasty i mean you know
come on those guys there's a lot of gays
in that family yeah but i don't know
they
they looked really gay at first i saw it
on uh the internet and they were like in
these golf shirts and [ __ ] and they were
all clean-shaven republicans right which
kind of means gay
right right and then they grew the
beards to get the uh show and
and i think they did have the southern
accents but i watched that show the
other day i think it's cr i i'm
transfixed by these reality shows
they're very good
you had your own reality show i had two
or three of them what was that so you
had roseanne's nuts which i loved yeah
there were more bleeps you had more
bleeps per minute than anything i've
ever seen they would say that i was
difficult
but you know that's how i talk they want
to see the real me i mean if they didn't
want to see the real me i could never
figure well why don't you go hire uh you
know
raquel welch or somebody right like that
right you don't want to see me i saw one
episode you were on like a
truck and you were like plowing through
the macadamia things and you were
clearing brush and
getting my aggression out yeah and
killing you know non-indigenous
um what do you call it colonial growth
off my
pure
pele nest so you add so the macadamia
stuff that is indigenous to no it's not
it's from new zealand really the mac see
the big island hawaii where i live that
was the world's uh
la la boratory
where all those people went and they did
experiments in the earth of what would
grow you know and so those those
macadamia nuts they're not indigenous
really they uh
they are from new zealand and they were
brought over at the very same time when
the pineapple which
is not indigenous to the big island of
hawaii was brought there too so they
were manufacturing this perfect cyborg
biosphere right then and they have been
since
the late 1800s on the big island you're
blowing my mind already you're telling
me macadamia
farmer but macadamia nuts and pineapples
are neither indigenous to hawaii no not
the kind they brought over
they brought the pineapple from other
hawaiian islands and then they brought
the papaya and the mango and they
totally gmo manufactured the uh
the papaya that's why you know that's
why i end up running for president
because
i was part of kicking
yeah monsanto's ass off the big island
hawaii and we did win and we did kick
monsanto out and i i was so proud of
that because all the time i'd be like
you know i meditate and stuff
so i'd be like what would be the best
words i always
meditate for the right words because i'm
a comic and that's what we do we're
always looking for a word
that fit and whatever i i very seldom
brag about myself and my writing and
stuff
or maybe i do it too much
it depends on how many drinks i've had
well you do have 18 cups here i'm not
sure what's going on here water coffee
and my specialty
the special tea yeah for my voice yeah
yeah we'll keep that one quiet remember
jackie gleason that was my favorite
thing i knew it as a little girl yeah
he'd take that drink or and jack part
two they'd act like they were drinking
you knew it you just looked for how
where the
you knew it was booze because they did
that bit so many times
people used to be able to drink on
television i know people they would be
smoking i mean johnny carson was smoking
cigarettes and they were drinking and
having a good time and now everything
swear they couldn't swear we can say
whatever you want you want to throw an f
bomb right now just for just an extra
one no because that kicks in my ocd oh
so if we load if we throw one in it
could unfurl the whole it will it will
so it's like don't even go there it's
like that first drink you know i i go to
alcoholics
isn't that the worst what do you want to
say i feel like i'm in therapy because
i'm talking about b arthur about b and
the gays great yeah
so but be in the game be gay
i don't know i don't know either i saw
her sing this song to her husband on
broadway because i went and said i saw
her play oh i saw the play yeah yeah
wasn't it it was wonderful it was
wonderful it was all like old all her
old stories and what it was like to be
trapped in that little tv box which you
know you you know all about i guess like
her voice so much
i think that that's what'll be missed is
that boys yeah it was such a genius once
in a lifetime voice and when she sang it
was so beautiful but it was her boy
singing
and uh boy she was a master of that yeah
few people are what do you think about
that that idea of that the the gays
rallied around the golden girls in a way
that they maybe didn't around roseanne
but you did
i mean that kiss i remember watching
that kiss whatever year that was maybe
97 or something and it was literally
people were watching it in bars all over
america yeah we were trying there wasn't
technology then but we were trying to
hook up phone calls to like a
central but now of course it'll all be
you know i don't know what they do now
yeah
bouncing off mars or something something
with more i know it's involved with mars
very technological now yeah so uh i wish
i was working then when it was high tech
like that well you're you're working
right now well in my own studio
you know i just got on this kick because
i have really bad ocd
but i just wanted to know what does it
feel like to um
own your own work and just like say what
you want to say and
be who you really are it it takes a lot
of sacrifice man yeah i mean we have
been working poured out the ass every
day we have been i've never worked
harder in my life than we've worked in
these last couple months as we've put
this thing together well you got to work
hard yeah
you got to pay the cost to be the boss
that ain't no [ __ ] yeah you own the
sitcom no you didn't own it i own a
percentage of it right that makes me
you know i could go like i do get
depressed over that
i owned 20 of my own work
and i put i'm the one that put my life
on the line
that certainly won any committee
involved there but every joke there was
a committee involved but at the final
hour
i just say what i want in front of the
camera and let the audience decide if i
got a bigger left than all the writers
then we kept that and if they got a
bigger left than me we kept that i mean
i cared about the product yeah and aside
from all the other names they call me
[ __ ] and all that [ __ ] cause you know
whatever
um you know it's important that an
artist control
his or her
own life and product and
everything i mean that [ __ ] ain't free
for somebody to take isn't it cool that
we're cutting out the networks now in a
way because look i mean we i think so
yeah like i own this thing i have no i
don't have to answer it anymore you know
you're gonna work hard too
you're not no
democrat you link a lot of this stuff
that's happening on colleges in the
movie you link it to sort of how we've
raised kids now so you want to you want
to kick the millennials while they're
down
i do
i i do as as i as i
travel through this land i think
i think this self-esteem movement has
really
is really the genesis of this we started
because i started thinking like
when i was 19 i didn't have any
self-esteem and
my thing was like i'm not going to tell
an adult what to do like i would never
dream if i was walking down the street
and i was like
16 and i'd passed a 45 year old guy and
he just went hey stop and i went well i
need to go give me 20
push-ups okay diamond hands or kind of
do a wide spread like i would have just
done it because he's a dude and he's
older than me and he told me to do
something that's how i was wired so
i started thinking like
well if i were 19 and i was on a college
campus
and i i was on a construction site but
if i was on a college campus and by the
way when i was on a construction site i
had a foreman go
he said go to my truck get my four foot
level out of my gun rack he had like a
four foot level hang on his gun rack and
i said
okay and i started walking the truck and
he goes hey run and i started running
because he told me to run because he's
older than i am he also had a gun rack
so it was probably a wise
game yeah where's the gun
run it probably wasn't all levels in
there run serpentine
so
i started thinking
if i was 19 and i was on a
college campus and they announced that
some
50 year old with a bunch of degrees was
coming to speak i would never go like
not
over my dead body i'd just be like oh
okay
all right and then someone would go
well adam he's going to talk about stuff
you disagree with and i'd go well he's
50 and has all the degrees so i guess
i'm probably wrong and then someone
would go
do does he have the right to speak here
and i go
of course it's not my campus i'm just
i'm i'm i'm basically this is a
four-year motel i'm living at i don't
own the building like who something for
me to and then if they went we're gonna
go rally and make create a human
blockade i'd be like why why just don't
go to the show
well i don't i don't get it and i
realize sort of like a sane functioning
person that's what you're saying you
would have acted like a
female should be well
how high does your self-esteem have to
be to go not on my watch
no way as
is david rubin or jordan
sorry jordan rubin or dave
ben shapiro you're combining all these
people combining them into one
one
horrible transforming yeah that's gonna
be that's gonna be
why
would
why why would that be my job
who am i to do that so if you think
about what that takes
that takes a life of grooming that takes
a life of don't let anyone tell you what
to do
you tell them what to do like you're
special
your opinion matters don't let anybody
you know
how so the self-esteem movement i
believe is super dangerous i mean
how are you going to put
world war ii get in a higgins landing
craft and go hit normandy
19 year olds with super high self-esteem
you think they're getting in that thing
you think they're going to
russian german pillbox hell no
no so this thing that we thought was
good like hey what if everyone just felt
really good about themselves like
that's good if you earn it
if you just
rub it on them
that ain't earning it and that's going
to lead to trouble so if we go a little
meta on that do you think that's
actually by design do you think that is
just like it's sort of just kind of like
liberals that wanted everybody to feel
good and it's just kind of nice or do
you think it was actually by design by
some some bad actors that push this
stuff out there to to weaken all of the
things that you that the movie's about
i think
it can be traced back to a gentleman
who's out of los angeles who
had an idea which is like
it was
and i'll paraphrase but it's like some
of these inner city kids and some of
these low-income kids or
single parent kids and stuff
they have low self-esteem like they
don't their dad abandoned them like they
don't feel good about themselves and if
they felt good about themselves they
would start excelling in school and get
out of gangs and not be involved with
crime so
how do we get them to feel good about
themselves and it's like well we can't
get their dad back in the house and we
can't give them an a in calculus when
they're failing calculus we're just
going to start telling them how good
they are and they'll feel good about
themselves and what ended up happening
is it turns out like criminals have high
self-esteem like
they didn't know it's a unintended
circumstance like i have a good heart
you know it's it's basically all that
stuff of like i have a good heart let's
build
big housing projects and let people live
and free in those and we'll give them
food and we'll level it's like yeah
you're really good it all sounds good
you have a great heart you've now ruined
a group of people that's how you ruin
people you you tell them you give them
things without earning it you give them
food without earning it you give them
housing without earning it or you give
them self-esteem without earning it you
don't earn it it doesn't work it morphs
into something bad and then comes back
in a weird kind of
vitriolic way all right we talked about
new york city yeah we talked about
afghanistan
seems like the segway to
where we're at right now in california
what do you make about what's going on
with this state we we both we talked
about it about a month ago on your show
yeah i was strongly considering leaving
like i was looking at real estate i had
a whole bunch of people begging me to
come to dallas i would have had a pretty
sweet operation over there yeah my
feeling right now is i want to stay and
fight here i like i love socal i love
you know i love the weather of course
and all that but like i built a good
life here we've got
friends
i like it here it's a freaking mess
absolute mess i think you're in a bit of
a similar situation i am and i i didn't
think about staying and fighting until i
spoke to you and i haven't stopped
thinking about that and i think you're
right um
i i was just in austin looking at
property and boy does that
oh
i know we probably i told you we're
probably looking at the same houses i'm
on truly like man when i could get in
austin the amount of money i can save
it's cheaper to live it's that you know
i don't pay that 13 tax or whatever it
is or 18
um so yeah i could save a lot of money
and um what's happening in california it
seems is businesses are leaving for just
that reason because it's very expensive
to do business here what california has
going for it is a very diversified
economy and amazing weather
and it's just a huge important state for
a lot of reasons but california was the
state that worked
and
we have a
democratic super majority
and uh if you look at local politics
it's it's just anytime you have a super
majority of any group i don't care if
it's republican or democrat i don't
think that's good for democracy
um your vote if you are someone who
leans even a little bit right doesn't
count save it stay home we don't care
and you aren't getting elected to local
office
you're not getting elected to to
government office you're not unless you
are pro big union across the board good
luck good luck otherwise
and i'm a member of a union i'm in sag
so i i understand the value of unions
but
it's expensive to do business and unless
you can push back a little bit or come
up with a compromise i don't i don't i'm
not bullish on california and that ain't
me i've talked to some very smart people
who are economic
animals and all of them agree and all of
them are looking to get out because
it's too expensive why why i live in
on skid row basically i'm in venice i've
been in venice for 25 years i love it
but i don't recognize my town anymore as
much
and you know it's gotten really bad over
there right it's not just gotten very
bad it's become profitable
because developers now can get these
government contracts i mean i can build
you i can build you a bunch of
apartments for 200 million dollars on
prime real estate on a parking lot and
on the beach if you'd like i'd be happy
to do that and we can just have we can
create a homeless uh
uh apartments peop for people who are
homeless and uh don't worry about doing
drugs or anything else we're not gonna
put any of those restrictions on you can
come and go as you like you know so so
there is something that see this is not
me but a scholar i had a long
conversation with called the the
homeless industrial complex
once there's money
in
bidding and getting
uh homeless shelters
for big developers you better be careful
so these people need to be put in
treatment the majority of the people on
the street is not a housing problem it's
not a housing problem it's not a housing
problem it is a mental health and
addiction problem and until we get
serious about that
uh we're we're going to be in big
trouble is it weird to you watching it
spread in different areas so venice
always had a certain amount of that now
it's definitely more but like hollywood
which also always had a certain amount
it's like kind of taking over hollywood
if you just go to straight up especially
now where there aren't as many other
people on the streets
now it just seems like all there are
kind of like transient people and
homeless and tents and
well you and as that inches closer to
west hollywood now it'll inch closer to
beverly hills and that that then is oh
my gosh that meant it gets pushed yeah
well you know they have their own police
force but yeah prop 47 and you can't
it's not criminalized they're all these
i voted for 47 because the way it was
phrased and it had it had the
again on the ballot i'm as i'm voting i
went well this makes sense i don't want
kids to be in a revolving door of crime
and and police chiefs back it and did
you read the whole thing i didn't that's
it i didn't have time
remiss but that's how they get you in
this state i think more than any other
during the last election there was this
one thing on the ballot about um you
know do you want it it was something
like this do you want to put 500 million
dollar
into education for you know blah blah
blah
and then there's essay just a giant
crazy essay on the whole thing and i
skipped all the way to the bottom and on
the bottom it says this can only be
repealed or reversed
by popular vote but nobody ever says
okay now we'll take the money from the
kids but that's government 101. that's
right you sell it exactly the packaging
thing you're talking about away nobody
reads the fine print and then you throw
it back on the people to be like oh
you'll have to take care of this deal
with this there's always blow back
there's always a ripple effect
no matter what the intentions are you
know we've spent something like three
trillion dollars on programs for the
poor how's that going how's it going you
know it it
it's very difficult i i i think at the
end of the day it's not about right or
left you've got to ask yourself do you
really think that a bloated bureaucracy
called the federal government
is the first line of defense is that the
best way to solve these problems
is it i don't i don't i don't think so
is government going to keep families
intact
is it government official or a
bureaucrat who studies family law or
whatever going to keep your family
intact are they going to are they going
to get you to take care of your kids are
they going to get you the skills that
you need in the 21st century the
ever-changing 21st century
uh it's a question yeah
maybe the answer is yes in some cases
but i don't know if that's always the
question the answer and you got to ask
those questions the problem we run into
is we go well i'm a republican i'm a
democrat i'm left i'm right there
there's no hold on hold on let's let's
go into what percentage of your money do
you want to give the government every
year every day i i pay something like 52
in taxes so half my day half my year is
working for someone else
half my day half my year is working for
someone else so how much more do you
want from me joining me today is a
stand-up comic and host of dennis miller
plus one on the rt network as well as
the dennis miller option podcast dennis
miller i've already said your name three
times what's up rubes welcome to the
reuben report beautiful pad here man i'm
trying to read you can tell a man by his
books and how am i doing his tchotchkes
i see you were a carlin fan which i find
in court little stephen pinker nba i
think your detractors would say this
indicates you're moving rightward
towards john birch participation
on the bottom where do you have the map
centered out
that odd confluence between south
america and or the globe i should say
south america and africa where it split
up and now i have a theory it looks like
they were together at one point yes
they've split apart and obviously the
west coast of africa with uh uh ivory
coast liberia is the most contentious
place on the planet and i think that's a
a sudden hard drive tremble from way
back when where a guy went out into his
yard in liberia once and said honey
what's this crack and then two weeks
later another continent i've oft
wondered how pangaea split
now i have a little there you go yeah
i'm giving you a little something of
everything here because we got lefties
we got righties look i got an american
flag in the controller i love the map i
always love to have a map in my studio
to feel satiated yeah so
you got two shows you've done a
bajillion things i said to you right
before i'm not even going to use notes i
try not to really look at my notes when
i talk to most guests anyway i thought
i'd just sit down and see what happens
you kind of just need to be wound up and
then you go right
well you know what but i i tell you as i
get older i need to be wound up and let
go less i just listen it's contentious
now i was more of a
i don't want to use the it's a tired
term firebrand but i was more willing to
engage lock antlers when i was young
i don't think people are going to change
their minds anymore i i don't want to be
the carnival barker on some freak show
people wear split we'll find out where
we go which way at each election in
between it's going to be contentious
uh at age 66 i don't want to wake up
every day and fight with people about
stuff they're not going to change their
mind on anyway so when i get going i
like to put on a good show you know
you're
you're spanking our gang let's put on a
show but i don't need the i don't need
to get going as much anymore so you're
like an evolved political satirist or
something
i just uh i used to dig the game when
you could budge somebody in an angst i
didn't need them to come over i never
thought that you're going to talk to
somebody and they were going to desert
their core beliefs and
come over your way but they at least you
could see them mulling i think mulling's
gone i could see hmm it's gone it's just
now people nobody's everybody's dug in
and
man i'm trying over here no i appreciate
it but like i said i i don't know you're
in
your 40s right i would have probably
fought a lot more then but i'm telling
you what you seem like just the time we
talked beforehand you seem like a smart
enough cat that's somewhere down the
road i can't see you fighting it into
the barn seem to be in love you know
beautiful family in the picture out here
got a great place you're kicking ass and
taking names career-wise yeah you should
do it now but at some point the the
harvest is uh
are you gonna do i'm into getting up and
reading taking a hike having a good meal
appreciating the fact i married the most
beautiful witty charming girl i ever met
adoring my sons watching some baseball
and then reading as i fall out to sleep
is that a tough thing though for a comic
to have to face no for me but do you
think for most comics that's like you
almost fear that you fear the okayness
because you won't have the fuel
it's a convenient it's a job yeah i'm i
was never very uh
i don't view show business as some sort
from the stone moment where you're
anointed
good job i grew up in pittsburgh and uh
my job what i was good at was i i would
think jokes up and then i tried to give
those jokes to somebody else to do and
then i found i didn't have the ego for
that once i saw somebody do a joke i
thought up on the tonight show and
carson laughing i'm not built for this i
better become the unlikely conduit but
i've never thought of myself as the
silver surfer comedian
yeah and so no i don't you know i don't
have any moment pangs or anything oh i
wish i was in the fray
it never was like that when i was in the
fray
were you always uh political
because i think i should get that job on
snl you have to become political yeah so
you weren't political before i used to
be a prop comic i remember working with
the you know i was never quite
carotopian but uh
i i got an actual word i think that's
probably in the dictionary now that's
depressing i uh
i did props when i first started because
i thought that visually that way but
then i remember i couldn't fit the props
in the overhead i had slight props and
then i thought you know i'm not going to
wait a half an hour at a
revolving car right for some inflatable
seat i could put on my head and say a
last four turning
i ditched out on that started writing
jokes like i said stole a couple of
other comedians saw them do them and
score with them and thought i've got to
be the guy so um
like i said it's very
uh i i didn't have a woosh whoosh thing
about stand up i remember thinking okay
this is a good career
kind of a decision so when you get the
weekend update situation the snl
situation then it's sort of like it was
political what what year did you started
snl
somewhere in the 80s somewhere somewhere
in the world i mean though i'm not doing
that deliberately yeah i just uh
i remember i was uh maybe like 89 or
something because i'm trying to remember
because you on snl
that that class was like my formative
comedy year class so i was like 12 13
around then and i think i think maybe
like 89 or something like that well some
people choose to think of themselves as
comedic visionaries i choose to think of
ourselves as ushering kids through
puberty where they uh if you were 12 or
13 yeah that's all we were there was 15
minutes off from jerking off yeah
but you guys did it
see i made it out okay
but i remember i was in baltimore and i
had auditioned for snl maybe a month
before
and then i remember um
they picked the cast usa today had a
picture of them i wasn't in it i was
still in baltimore and i was so tough at
that point because on your way up you
have to be tough you didn't stand up in
new york 12 years
i was a gladiator
and i remember seeing that picture i
didn't have a crestfallen thing i think
i came close to that all right keep
going
uh then i was up doing letterman and
somebody came into the letterman
dressing room and said listen lauren
michaels wants to see you on eight or no
17 where his office was and i said
jesus i knew something was he's not
calling me down to revisit me to tell me
why yeah you're really not getting it
but i'm thinking maybe i get a shot on
it as a comedian or something like
stephen wright would come on sam once in
a
while
so um
i went down i knew it was going to be
something good but then i i walked in i
remember it's one of those moments that
stick in your head lauren sits at the
end of the thing he's got one of those
green domed glasses
lights on his desk you know that gives
it that arthur conan doyle feel he's got
the quarter glasses on reading scripts
or something and over his shoulders the
empire state building and i remember it
being like red white and blue and it
wasn't fourth of july or anything but he
looks up and he goes hey dennis miller i
go hey lauren he says how would you like
to do weekend update and i said i'd like
that a lot i said i'll see you tomorrow
at around 11. i said all right sir i
walked out and i remember thinking i'm
not a big drinker but i remember
thinking i'm going to go get four
fingers or something brown on the rocks
and knock this down because this is
pivotal and that was magical i don't
want to act like i'm sitting over here
yeah disputing i'm talking about stand
up i was kind of step by step maginot
line move it six inches fall back four
move it four
but when that happened i remember
thinking all right take some mental
polaroids here don't be blase about this
because that's its own defense mechanism
this is a big deal chevy chase did this
you're gonna do it now enjoy it until
you either become a success or get
whacked so i did enjoy it a long way i i
took all those moments and you know the
first time you sit in that seat yeah
yeah count your dad i just thought
all right i might go out but i'm going
out on my shield here
so even though you weren't purely
political they they pegged you for that
were you is that what is that is that
what you wanted did you want to do more
i wanted any hook
i'm not a character guy i used to try to
stay out of the snl sketches because uh
you know when you're with geniuses
carvey's comedic genius love it's uh the
sketch-wise the genius phil
the ultimate blue guy the only guy i
never thought i'd see a guy like danny
and phil got in the realm with him and i
always thought well this is a serious
play mike myers comes in so you got four
leads there who can kill the ball i'm
the fifth guy in the sketch i'm the
bartender saying here's your gimlet and
yet i got to be there blocking it for
three and a half hours so i used to go
around and say to writers when they
wrote me and i'd say don't put me in i
want to be like the dh i want to pick a
rock song swing the weighted bat down
the tunnel come out and you know hit the
ball for 10 minutes and by the end you
had that right yeah it was a groovy job
and i used to
i'd probably been in around a dozen
sketches over the years and they were
ones where i thought oh this is good i
should stay in this because i want to
see uh i want to see this when i get
older uh it's a wonderful life the next
chapter you know you knew when something
was going to be a big hit if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about comedy instead of
the non-stop yelling you get everywhere
else check out our comedy playlist and
if you want to watch full interviews on
a variety of topics check out our full
episode playlist they're both right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell